Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent le monde".
La santé à vif.
Situation paradoxale :
alors que la médecine française
est toujours de grande qualité
et aussi
efficiente tant au niveau
des hôpitaux publics
que du secteur privé,
alors que l'assurance maladie permet
une couverture médicale remarquable,
jusqu'à une quasi-gratuité
des soins,
alors que nos mécanismes
de solidarité
sont opérationnels jusque
et y compris
dans le cas d'épidémies,
et même de pandémie,
comme on l'a vu avec la covid-19,
oui, malgré tous ces satisfecit,
le système de santé
ne fonctionne pas bien
et tout ou presque est à revoir
dans ce qui fut,
à la sortie des Trente Glorieuses,
c'est-à-dire entre 1945 et 1975,
et jusqu'au début
du 21e siècle,
un modèle d'excellence.
Plus que des trous
dans la raquette socio-médicale,
ce modèle semble à bout de souffle.
Qu'on en juge :
une difficulté d'accès,
des patients aux soignants,
à l'hôpital
comme en médecine de ville ;
des milliers de postes de soignants,
médecins, infirmiers
vacants sur tout le territoire,
avec des asymétries territoriales
pénalisant les populations
précaires et fragiles ;
un paiement à l'acte inadapté
et des revendications de revenu
aussi justifiées que permanentes ;
une mauvaise coordination des soins
entre le privé et le public ;
une recherche médicale en baisse,
une industrie biomédicale
à la traîne,
on l'a vu avec ce fameux
vaccin français
qui n'est pas arrivé
concernant la covid.
Bref, cet inventaire
n'est pas exhaustif,
mais il reste à comprendre
les raisons de la dégradation
de notre système de santé
dans une société qu'on pourrait
qualifier de solitarisation,
tant les gens sont seuls,
ou, en tout cas,
ont ce ressenti de solitude.
Bref, notre joyau social,
envié par tant de pays,
est en danger et,
pour expliquer un peu
cette situation,
je vais le faire
avec mes invités :
Arnaud Robinet,
vous êtes à la fois médecin,
président de la Fédération
hospitalière
de France et vous êtes
également maire de Reims.
-Je tiens à préciser,
je ne suis pas médecin,
je suis docteur ès sciences
en pharmacologie.
Je ne veux pas usurper un titre !
-Merci
de ce correctif.
Donc vous êtes, euh...
Vous présidez cette fédération...
-Tout à fait.
-...dont on va
largement parler.
Jacques Milliez,
vous êtes gynécologue,
professeur des universités
et vous êtes membre
de l'Académie nationale
de médecine.
Patrick Pelloux,
vous êtes médecin hospitalier
et urgentiste.
Et Jérôme Marty,
vous êtes bien médecin
et président de l'UFML,
c'est quoi, l'UFML,
en deux mots ?
-L'Union française
pour une médecine libre.
-Alors, écoutez, la situation
de la santé en France pose problème.
J'aimerais avoir votre diagnostic
et aussi un pronostic
sur le manque de soignants
et les solutions envisagées.
Alors on évoque
d'un côté le vieillissement,
le numerus closus,
la répartition territoriale
anarchique,
la confusion des compétences.
C'est quoi, votre diagnostic,
Arnaud Robinet ?
Un premier diagnostic.
-Aujourd'hui,
tout ça est la résultante de quoi ?
D'une gestion purement comptable
depuis des dizaines d'années,
depuis 20 ou 30 ans.
Si on prend la question
du nombre de médecins,
rappelez-vous,
il y a à peu près 15 ou 20 ans,
avec l'accord
de l'ensemble des syndicats,
il faut aussi le préciser,
on considérait que le trou
de la Sécurité sociale était
du fait de trop de médecins,
que plus il y en avait,
plus on allait creuser ce trou.
Donc on n'a pas du tout anticipé,
par rapport notamment
aux besoins de la population,
notamment avec ce vieillissement
de la population,
une chance pour notre pays,
c'est aussi le symbole
de l'excellence de la médecine,
mais derrière, donc,
nous n'avons pas anticipé.
Et puis, tout ça, bien sûr,
cette gestion purement
comptable bien évidemment
a amené à des difficultés
d'économies pour l'hôpital public,
en 10 ans, 10 milliards d'euros
d'économies ont été faites
sur le dos de l'hôpital public,
donc derrière,
les conditions de travail
se sont dégradées,
donc un manque d'attractivité
pour la filière
hospitalière,
que ce soit le médical
ou le paramédical.
Et nous payons aujourd'hui
les frais de cette gestion
purement comptable.
-On va entrer dans le détail,
mais votre diagnostic à vous,
Jacques Milliez ?
Un premier diagnostic parce que...
-Oui, un premier diagnostic,
c'est que c'est sûr
que notre système de santé
est malade,
il est atteint d'une polypathologie
et, si je peux prendre
une comparaison médicale,
c'est comme les maladies orphelines,
c'est-à-dire qu'on a un diagnostic
mais pas de traitement.
Ou plutôt,
si on a des traitements,
on n'a pas le mode d'emploi.
Je prends un exemple
par les urgences :
pour essayer d'éteindre l'incendie
des urgences, c'est bien connu,
c'était l'an dernier,
le ministre de la Santé,
François Braun,
a sorti le carnet de chèque.
Bien.
L'idée et la stratégie
étaient d'orienter cet argent
vers les centres privés
d'accueil des urgences
pour décharger le public,
mais aussi de donner
des incitations financières
pour attirer vers les services
d'urgences publics
des soignants nouveaux,
un sang neuf.
Seulement, le sang neuf,
où est-ce qu'on le prend ?
Si on le prend dans ce qu'on,
pour faciliter les choses,
dans ce qu'on appellerait
les services d'aval,
c'est creuser un trou
pour en combler un autre.
Et déjà, services d'aval,
ils ont beaucoup de difficultés,
donc les urgentistes ne peuvent pas.
Donc la question qui se pose,
c'est comment faire venir
ou revenir à l'hôpital les gens
qui ne veulent pas y travailler
ou qu'on a mis dehors ?
Et là, on n'a pas
vraiment de réponse.
Mais si je peux ajouter
simplement un mot,
c'est que je crois
qu'il faut aussi
avoir conscience qu'on vit
dans un monde nouveau.
Alors c'est pas Christophe Colomb,
mais je pense que c'est
un monde différent
et si j'en prends un seul exemple :
les jeunes sur le marché du travail
ne veulent plus travailler
aux conditions
qui étaient les nôtres,
les horaires décalés,
les salaires minables,
ils veulent
une vie privée et, là,
je parle pas des soignants,
je parle des chauffeurs de bus
à la RATP et de tous les autres.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait à la RATP ?
-On va entrer dans tout le détail,
mais j'aimerais avoir
une première image avec vous,
donc qu'est-ce qui fait
que ce modèle
d'excellence,
dont on parlait il y a encore
quelques années,
sinon quelques décennies,
soit aujourd'hui troué,
Patrick Pelloux ?
Une première image,
si je puis dire,
car le public le ressent
comme ça aujourd'hui.
-Pour faire suite
à ce que vous venez de dire,
parce que, en fait,
c'est complémentaire,
je suis d'accord avec...
-Vous pouvez être en dissonance.
-Non, pour faire suite à ça,
si y avait un exemple à dire,
c'est la prise en charge
des personnes âgées,
comme a dit,
en fait, Jacques,
à l'instant...
-Jacques Milliez.
-...qui sont atteints
de polypathologie et où l'hôpital,
assistance publique,
l'hôpital public, est devenu
une prise en charge de spécialités,
voire de surspécialités
et de sur-surspécialités.
C'est-à-dire qu'on s'est éloigné
de la globalité du malade.
Et la formation des médecins,
la formation des médecins,
elle est faite
par des universitaires
qui ne les rapprochent pas
du monde du travail mais veulent,
aujourd'hui,
je parle pas de ta génération,
mais la génération actuelle,
ils veulent que les étudiants
en médecine deviennent
des super-universitaires,
des chercheurs de mitochondrie.
Or il y a le quotidien,
c'est de voir les gens,
et tu t'aperçois que,
en fait, avec le temps,
ceux qui sont valorisés,
dans le monde de la santé,
sont les plus éloignés des malades.
-Je voudrais vous faire
préciser cette chose-là :
vous êtes en train de dire,
si j'ai bien compris,
que, aujourd'hui,
les patients sont
en meilleure santé,
d'une certaine manière,
car il y a toutes les conditions
de l'environnement,
mais qu'on n'a pas pris
en considération cette chose-là
et qu'on pense régler tout ça
par de la technique,
de la technique
et de la technique ?
-C'est très important, ça,
et ça rejoint ce que disait
monsieur Robinet avant,
c'est-à-dire qu'on a cru que,
en améliorant l'environnement,
on améliorerait la santé.
On a oublié le vieillissement
de la population, qui a explosé,
et le vieillissement
a été révélé en 2003,
avec la canicule de 2003,
on s'est aperçu
que les gens vieillissaient.
Les gens vieillissent,
et de plus en plus, et en effet,
y a eu cette... façon
de voir les malades
comme une continuité
de leur environnement social :
en améliorant le social,
ils allaient bien.
C'est beaucoup plus compliqué
et on s'est trompé.
Faut juste reconnaître,
ça fait 20 à 30 ans
qu'on s'est totalement trompé
sur la santé.
Et je vous redis,
je sais pas si j'aurai l'occasion,
il faut redonner de l'importance,
à la ville
comme à l'hôpital,
aux médecins qui sont
au pied du lit du malade.
-Jérôme Marty,
vous avez écouté
ce qui vient d'être dit
et j'aimerais avoir votre avis
parce que vous,
vous défendez
les médecins de ville.
Tout ça est arrivé comme ça,
par hasard ?
On découvre,
alors que c'est un phénomène,
qu'il s'agisse du vieillissement,
qu'il s'agisse du numerus clausus,
etc., c'est des choses
qui ont été, qui sont datées,
donc comment
vous expliquez cette...
-Rien n'est arrivé par hasard,
mais je voudrais rebondir
sur une réflexion que vous avez eue
en tout début d'émission,
parler de notre système solidaire,
qui est un joyau.
On est le seul pays du monde
où on opère à coeur ouvert un SDF.
On le dira jamais assez.
Et ce système qui va très mal
continue à tourner.
Pourquoi il tourne ?
Il tourne parce que
les gens dont parlait
Patrick tout à l'heure,
qui sont les mains qui soignent,
qu'ils soient
à l'hôpital ou en ville,
continuent à tenir
le système à bout de bras
dans des conditions déplorables,
ils sont épuisés,
et pourtant, ça tourne.
Mais on doit se demander
jusqu'à quand ?
Parce que oui,
ce système va très mal
et qu'on exerce à l'hôpital
ou qu'on exerce en ville,
quand on a l'expérience
qu'on peut avoir
avec 20 ans ou plus
de pratique,
on doit dire qu'on n'a
jamais connu de situation
comme celle d'aujourd'hui.
Et c'est venu d'une certaine
idée économique du soin,
en 96, monsieur Juppé
a créé l'ONDAM,
l'Objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie,
avec toutes les dépenses
dans une enveloppe contrainte
et on n'a plus regardé la santé
que sous l'angle du coût.
On a oublié ce qu'elle pouvait
apporter au pays,
non seulement en termes de richesse,
mais en termes
de socialisation,
en termes
de professionnalisation,
en termes de...
-Oui, mais monsieur Marty,
l'espérance de vie
a continué à croître,
malgré ce que vous dites.
-Dans l'espérance de vie,
le déterminant santé, c'est 20 %.
Faut pas oublier l'amélioration
de la pollution,
de l'accidentologie
par l'amélioration des voitures,
pas que de la santé,
c'est pas que de la santé.
Mais aujourd'hui,
il n'y a pas un seul Français,
pas un Français, vous m'entendez,
qu'il soit en ville,
à la campagne,
en zone semi-rurale,
qui ne sache pas les difficultés
d'accès aux soins.
Et c'est la résultante
des politiques sanitaires
successives.
Donc juste, j'en termine,
des criminels ont poignardé
la santé et il y a des empreintes
sur le manche.
-Vous traitez carrément
les politiques de criminels ?
-Sans aller trop loin,
je pense que, si vous voulez,
on n'a pas voulu tenir compte
de la richesse de ce pays,
des mains qui soignent,
on a totalement oublié ça,
on n'a pas voulu
se pencher sur ces soignants,
qui tiennent à bout de bras
le système et,
à force de les ignorer,
on les a oubliés.
Ca, c'est catastrophique.
-Une question précise :
aujourd'hui,
qu'est-ce qu'on a le plus besoin ?
On dit que la technique est là.
Est-ce que c'est des généralistes ?
Est-ce que c'est des pédiatres ?
Est-ce que c'est des urgentistes ?
-Tout !
-Des gériatres ?
-Vous avez besoin de généralistes,
des spécialistes libéraux,
parce que sans eux,
l'hôpital ne peut pas aller mal,
vous avez besoin d'aides-soignants
et d'hospitaliers,
sans eux, la médecine de ville
ne peut pas aller mal, bien,
les deux systèmes sont
profondément interfacés.
On a besoin de soignants,
de sens et de soignants heureux.
Vous ne pouvez exercer la médecine
que si vous êtes heureux.
Aujourd'hui, vous n'avez plus
que des soignants inquiets,
ce qui explique que la santé
s'effondre aussi.
-Mais alors, monsieur Robinet,
pour nos spectateurs,
que manque-t-il,
concrètement ?
Est-ce que ce sont des gériatres,
des pédiatres ?
Des gynécologues ?
A l'hôpital, il manque quoi ?
-Il manque de tout,
de toutes les spécialités.
On peut parler
de gynéco-obstétriciens,
de psychiatres, de pédopsychiatres,
de pédiatres, de gériatres,
dans toutes les spécialités,
il manque, il y a des postes vacants
et donc, aujourd'hui,
ce qui est indispensable,
l'urgence est de mener
une politique d'attractivité,
de mettre en avant
les métiers hospitaliers.
Je suis toujours stupéfait
des campagnes
de communication
du ministère de la Défense,
des dizaines de millions d'euros
mettent en avant
tous les métiers.
Pourquoi pas pour la santé ?
Faisons des grandes
campagnes de communication !
C'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga,
mais mettons en avant ces métiers.
L'attractivité n'est pas
uniquement la rémunération,
même si je vous rejoins sur le sujet
de la rémunération à l'hôpital,
mais ce sont les conditions
de travail,
c'est avoir le bien-être
au travail.
Moi, quand je vois des infirmières,
des aides-soignantes qui me disent :
monsieur le président,
j'aime mon métier mais là,
j'en peux plus car je considère
que je le fais mal,
je peux pas m'occuper
de la personne âgée
en service Alzheimer,
en EHPAD, et donc je suis mal,
je ne peux plus faire mon métier
alors que c'est une vocation,
aujourd'hui, je me sens mal,
j'aime l'hôpital,
j'aime mon métier
mais je ne le fais pas
comme je devrais le faire
et c'est ce qui, je dirais,
me donne envie de quitter
le système de santé.
-Monsieur Pelloux,
pour répondre à la question
et pour qu'on reste pas
dans des généralités :
est-ce qu'il manque
des urgentistes en France ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
-Parce que c'est le premier
accès à l'hôpital,
l'urgentiste.
-Nous l'avons vu cet été où,
pour la première fois
de notre histoire,
nous avons fermé, à peu près,
à intervalles réguliers
et dans le temps
de manière différente,
à peu près une centaine,
150 à peu près services d'urgences
par manque de médecins,
par manque d'infirmières, etc.
Ce que dit Arnaud Robinet
est intéressant,
c'est que, d'un coup,
l'Armée fait des campagnes
pour dire : venez travailler,
la santé en fait pour dire :
ne venez pas à l'hôpital.
Vous voyez la différence
de communication ?
Et en effet,
on manque de médecins
et, quand vous vous retournez
vers les universitaires,
qui tiennent les années d'études,
ils vous disent...
Attention, c'est eux
un peu les responsables,
les gens de l'ombre, là,
les universitaires,
les doyens, c'est eux,
les responsables,
car pourquoi
on n'augmente pas
le nombre d'étudiants
en médecine en France ?
Pourquoi ?
Parce que les doyens passent
leur temps à dire :
on en a trop, on pourra pas
en former plus.
Et ils refusent ce qui est
demandé par notamment la FHF
et les directeurs
des hôpitaux et les médecins
des hôpitaux généraux, etc.,
et la médecine de ville, de dire :
on prend des étudiants en stage,
prenons-les !
Seulement, vous avez un combat,
faut bien le savoir,
entre les CHU
et les autres hôpitaux
pour que les autres hôpitaux
n'aient pas d'étudiants.
Vous voyez, on marche sur la tête,
parce qu'on a la capacité
de former des étudiants,
mais simplement,
vous avez un petit nombre,
je vois l'image
de Voltaire derrière vous,
ça reprend
son propos :
un petit nombre
qui gère un grand nombre.
Et ce petit nombre,
vous n'arrivez pas à leur parler.
-Monsieur Marty,
qui est responsable et qui a donné
cette idée fallacieuse
qu'il fallait un numerus clausus ?
-Arnaud Robinet l'a dit,
les médecins sont
aussi responsables.
Les syndicats de médecins ont
défendu le numerus clausus.
C'est un peu ce qu'on a connu
avec les pharmaciens
quand ils ont accepté des quotas,
vous aviez un rapport de 1 à 7
entre zones sur-dotées
et les zones sous-dotées.
Et les médecins, pour protéger
leur activité, ont dit,
avec les politiques,
qu'on allait diminuer le nombre.
-Qui a pris la décision
de réduire le nombre de lits
dans les hôpitaux ?
Bah oui.
-Mais...
-Ca, c'est les années 74.
-Les années 74
et on a continué, notamment,
avec cette injonction notamment
donnée aux établissements publics
vers plus d'ambulatoire, sauf que,
derrière plus d'ambulatoire,
c'est une prise en charge du patient
à la sortie de l'hôpital,
donc la médecine de ville,
le généraliste,
les spécialistes et,
malheureusement, le constat est que,
par manque de médecins,
cet ambulatoire ne fonctionne pas
comme il devrait.
Et cette fermeture de lits
est aussi corrélée
au manque de personnel
dans nos hôpitaux.
Quand l'hôpital
public accueille 85 %
des patients covid,
durant ces deux dernières années,
derrière, ça amène à l'activation
des fameux plans blancs
donc on transfère des infirmières,
des aides-soignantes
dans le service covid.
Bah, derrière, vous êtes obligé
de fermer des lits
parce qu'il y a plus personne.
-Oui, mais y a quand même
une question qui fâche.
Trois d'entre vous, ici,
sont médecins,
vous, vous avez une responsabilité
hospitalière.
La formation d'un médecin,
aujourd'hui,
c'est six ou sept ans,
avec une spécialité...
-C'est 10 ou 12 ans !
-Avec une spécialité,
ça fait largement 10 ans.
-Non, ça fait 15 !
-Ou 10 à 15,
selon ce que vous souhaitez.
-On sera bientôt
en formation jusqu'à la retraite.
-Pourquoi pas,
mais alors,
si on veut remédier à ça,
ça va prendre quelques années,
or est-ce que les médecins
ne se sont pas opposés,
pardonnez-moi,
à une complémentarité
qui viendrait des infirmiers,
des infirmières,
de l'ensemble des paramédicaux,
pour avoir un encadrement sanitaire
infiniment plus étoffé ?
-Non, mais y a plein d'idées,
dans ce que vous dites.
Comprendre ce qui s'est
passé dans les années 70,
c'est par exemple
comprendre la construction
des autoroutes, très important :
on construit l'autoroute A6
et, en même temps, on construit
un hôpital tous les 50 kilomètres,
car il y a l'accidentologie,
il faut mettre les gens à l'hôpital.
On n'en est plus là,
ça a évolué,
y a eu en effet des progrès
sur la sécurité routière, etc.
Donc on a fermé
et regroupé ces hôpitaux.
Mais l'économie, du coup,
est allée trop loin
et l'économie, en effet,
comme dit monsieur Robinet
fort justement,
on est allé trop loin
dans l'économie de santé
et maintenant,
on est en dessous
de la moyenne européenne
pour le nombre de lits médicaux,
chirurgicaux et obstétriques.
-En PNB,
on n'est l'est pas.
-Si, on est en dessous.
-On est entre 12
et 14 % du PNB.
-Mais on a chuté,
on a chuté drastiquement
et je vous rappelle juste,
et je parle sous couvert
du professeur Milliez,
c'est que d'un coup,
on a l'un des plus
mauvais chiffres
en mortalité péri-infantile
et accouchements,
alors qu'on était les meilleurs.
-Vous ne répondez pas à ma question,
peut-être
que monsieur Marty va y répondre.
Pourquoi on n'a pas accepté
une complémentarité médicale
qui vienne de non-médicaux,
si je puis dire, de non-médecins,
avec les infirmiers et infirmières ?
-Je vois bien
où vous voulez m'amener,
mais elle existe
tous les jours, la complémentarité,
on a un exercice transversal,
avec les infirmières,
les pharmaciens, etc.
Un chiffre qu'il faut avoir en tête,
parce que si on l'oublie,
on comprend pas,
notamment la médecine de ville :
non seulement il faut 10 ans
pour former un médecin,
mais il faut 10 ans
pour qu'il s'installe.
Donc entre les deux,
20 ans se passent.
Ca veut dire aussi que,
aujourd'hui, là,
ce jour,
vous avez
potentiellement 40 000
à 50 000 médecins qui attendent
de s'installer et qui bénéficient
de la meilleure formation du monde,
parce que l'école
française
est une des meilleurs du monde,
et pourquoi ils s'installent pas ?
Parce qu'on a rendu leur métier
si peu attractif
qu'ils réfléchissent 10 ans,
craignant que le bilan
économique ne soit
pas pérenne.
-C'est les médecins eux-mêmes
qui rendent l'attractivité
de la profession,
c'est pas l'Etat qui va les rendre
attractifs.
-Eh si,
parce que l'Etat a la main sur tout,
la main sur l'organisation du soin,
l'Etat définit le poids
administratif de l'exercice,
les temps de non-soin,
il ne nettoie pas votre profession
et vous voilà avec des actes
n'ayant plus lieu d'être
et qui vous prennent du temps.
Quand vous rentrez le soir,
après avoir vu 30 ou 40 patients,
vous savez que vous avez laissé
10 ou 15 patients
au bord de la route
et vous ne pouvez pas l'accepter.
-Peut-être que Jacques Milliez
va répondre
sur la complémentarité
avec les infirmiers,
les infirmières et tout le personnel
paramédical.
-C'est exactement le sujet,
exactement le sujet.
Pour faire revenir ou faire venir
les infirmiers
et les infirmières à l'hôpital...
-Et leur donner plus
de compétences !
-...on leur propose,
attends, Emile,
on leur propose
de revaloriser la fonction
en leur déléguant
des tâches
et en permettant un accès
direct des patients
vers les infirmiers,
ce à quoi des médecins s'opposent
parce qu'ils pensent
que ça peut les court-circuiter.
Bon, moi, je suis gynécologue
et j'ai assisté à l'émancipation
de la profession de sage-femme.
Les sages-femmes,
c'est différent, elles font partie
de la profession médicale,
néanmoins, sur le temps,
elles sont de compétence
médicale réglementée
et j'ai vu leur complémentarité
énormément évoluer.
Les écoles de sages-femmes
étaient dirigées
par des gynécologues,
obligatoirement,
j'en étais,
ce sont maintenant
les sages-femmes qui dirigent,
elles ont le droit de faire
des échographies obstétricales,
de prescrire,
de s'occuper de la santé des femmes
même non enceintes,
elles prescrivent la contraception,
elles participent
aux IVG médicamenteuses
et elles ont une filière
maintenant qui...
l'IGAS vient de proposer
d'augmenter encore
la compétence
des sages-femmes
par une sixième année d'étude,
qui est un troisième cycle court,
qui va déboucher sur un doctorat
en science de la maïeutique.
Est-ce que ça a été
fait au détriment
de l'activité des gynécologues ?
Non.
Est-ce que ça a été fait,
est-ce qu'on peut
transposer ça à la profession
des infirmiers ?
A mon avis, non, pourquoi ?
Parce que y a jamais eu tant pénurie
de sages-femmes en hôpital,
jamais.
Elles ne veulent plus
travailler en salle
d'accouchement.
Le Collège des gynécologues
vient de lancer un SOS :
salles de naissances,
c'est la panique.
Donc l'éventail s'est
tellement ouvert
que les jeunes sages-femmes
ne veulent plus
travailler là
où on a besoin d'elles,
c'est-à-dire en salle de travail.
Donc c'est nécessaire
mais sûrement pas suffisant.
-On va entrer
dans le détail,
à la fois au niveau
de l'hôpital et au niveau
de la médecine libérale, bon,
vous avez dit, avec éloquence,
que le système de santé,
aujourd'hui,
ne fonctionne pas,
si y avait quelque chose à faire,
en urgence, à l'hôpital,
monsieur Robinet,
qu'est-ce que vous souffleriez
à monsieur Macron,
puisque nous sommes,
en France,
dans un système vertical,
où les impulsions
viennent d'en haut ?
-C'est une question très difficile
pour la simple et bonne raison
qu'il n'y a pas une urgence
mais des urgences.
Vous savez,
le système de santé français,
il ne va pas évoluer si on s'attaque
uniquement à l'hôpital.
Beaucoup de réformes ont été
qualifiées d'hospitalo-centristes.
On a vu que ça fonctionnait pas.
Je reviens sur ce que disait
Jean Marty tout à l'heure :
l'hôpital va fonctionner
si la médecine de ville marche,
et vice versa.
Donc il faut renforcer
cette coopération, complémentarité.
-Avec la médecine de ville.
-Et aussi
avec le privé.
Aujourd'hui, on a des difficultés
avec le privé,
notamment les urgences.
Quand on ferme les urgences
dans une clinique privée,
sans plan blanc activé
dans le privé, forcément,
c'est l'hôpital
qui en subit les conséquences.
-Est-ce que vous diriez,
monsieur Robinet,
petite précision,
que la loi Bachelot 2010
était scandaleuse en écartant
les médecins de la gestion
des hôpitaux ?
-OUI.
-Sans langue de bois.
-J'étais jeune député
à l'époque,
je n'ai pas voté la loi HPST.
C'était le premier texte de loi
que je devais voter
en arrivant comme jeune député,
c'est le premier texte de loi
que je n'ai pas voté
parce que ça ne répondait pas
forcément aux besoins de l'hôpital,
notamment à son fonctionnement.
-Il faut corriger ça
aujourd'hui ?
-Aujourd'hui,
quand je vois que le président
agite d'un chiffon rouge,
comme priorité,
la question de la gouvernance
de l'hôpital,
pour moi, c'est pas l'urgence,
y a d'autres urgences,
d'autres dossiers à considérer.
Aujourd'hui, depuis 2021,
cette gouvernance bicéphale
existe entre la direction générale
et le président
ou la présidente de la CME.
Et in fine, dans un établissement,
comme dans toute structure,
quelqu'un prend les décisions,
endosse les responsabilités pénales.
Mais aujourd'hui, et d'ailleurs
la conférence des présidents
de CME a fait un communiqué
il y a 24 heures
en disant que ce n'était pas
l'urgence dans ce que l'on attend
pour qu'évolue le système de santé.
Cela fonctionne dans 95 %
des établissements publics de santé,
il y a la loi 2021,
on peut évidemment l'évaluer,
voir comment ça fonctionne,
mais ce n'est pas l'urgence.
Mais ce serait
intéressant de redonner
peut-être un peu plus
de place aux élus locaux
au sein de l'hôpital,
notamment arrêter ce conseil
de surveillance et revenir
à un conseil d'administration,
avec comme patron aussi
le président du conseil
d'administration
qui a, aussi, je dirais,
des objectifs,
qui connaît son territoire,
qui peut participer au développement
du système de santé chez lui
en connaissant les besoins
et attentes des citoyens
et qui peut également permettre
de mettre autour de la table
les acteurs de la santé,
les associations d'usagers,
la médecine de ville,
les collectivités,
les établissements publics
et les établissements privés.
C'est ce qu'on appelle, à la FHF,
la responsabilité populationnelle,
en se donnant des objectifs
en termes de prévention
et d'accès aux soins.
-Une petite précision,
puisque vous vous occupez
de la Fédération hospitalière,
on dit que les gros budgets
passent vers le technique,
là où il y a le plus
d'applications
scientifiques.
Est-ce qu'il faudrait pas
mieux dispatcher ça
et ne pas consacrer
l'essentiel du budget
à la technicité médicale,
mais plutôt que ça aille
vers les urgences,
vers des disciplines
qui n'exigent pas
de technicité ?
-Non, mais on peut pas opposer
l'un à l'autre.
Evidemment qu'on a besoin d'hommes,
de femmes qui pratiquent
la médecine,
je dirais au pied du lit du patient,
et la médecine,
c'est la relation humaine et ça,
rien ne l'enlèvera,
mais on ne peut pas non plus
mettre de côté l'évolution,
la technique, l'innovation...
-J'ai pas dit mettre de côté,
mais redispatcher
vers d'autres disciplines
qui sont moins
pourvues.
-Je pense que c'est pas le sujet,
excusez-moi,
c'est pas ce qui améliorera
le fonctionnement de l'hôpital
et la prise en charge du patient.
Je pense que les deux sont
vraiment nécessaires.
Par contre, je pensais
que vous alliez me poser
la question pour l'hôpital public
sur l'administration,
y a un peu un fantasme
qui circule en disant que,
dans les hôpitaux,
y a trop d'administratif
par rapport au patient.
L'administratif,
en hôpital,
c'est 10 % et on y inclut...
-Oui, mais il peut y avoir 10 %
et de la bureaucratie.
-Mais on inclut dans ces 10 %
les secrétaires médicaux.
Je rappelle que,
dans les autres fonctions publiques,
territoriales ou fonctions d'Etat,
voilà, c'est entre 15 et 16 %.
Donc il faut aussi remettre
les choses à leur place.
Aujourd'hui, l'hôpital public
a besoin d'une chose,
il a besoin d'hommes et de femmes,
d'une réorganisation
je dirais en son sens,
il a besoin
de visibilité et, notamment,
c'est pour ça, en parlant d'ONDAM,
on demande des plans pluriannuels
pour une visibilité
sur le moyen et long termes,
qu'on accentue la prévention
et que, enfin, on arrive,
dans ce pays,
à coordonner la médecine de ville
et l'hôpital public,
c'est une nécessité indispensable.
-Toujours sur l'hôpital,
Patrick Pelloux,
vous, vous êtes urgentiste,
on dit que...
l'urgentiste à l'hôpital,
c'est le généraliste du pauvre,
c'est-à-dire que,
si on peut pas aller se faire
soigner ailleurs,
on va voir un urgentiste,
et donc embouteillage
et, quelquefois,
des soins insuffisants, etc.
Vous adhérez à ça ?
-C'est pas une insulte.
-Bah non.
-Généraliste n'est pas une insulte.
Pauvre n'est pas une insulte.
Je suis là pour les gens
qui sont pauvres,
et les gens qui sont pauvres,
c'est souvent
ceux qui sont avec la maladie,
vous savez,
nous serons tous dépendants.
-La question
n'était pas morale de ma part,
elle était en termes
d'impossibilité...
-La morale était dans l'ombre
de votre question.
-En aucun cas,
y avait un jugement moral,
mais y avait
une question d'accès aux soins.
-Ecoutez, les urgences,
il faut que ça reste
ouvert à tout le monde,
quand vous voulez,
c'est la garantie
de la sécurité pour la population,
c'est le phare dans la nuit
de la société qui est, en fait,
une société
qui abandonne l'autre.
Vous avez vu comment
on abandonne l'autre,
on vous fait croire que vous n'êtes
pas seul avec 100 000 followers
sur votre compte machin,
mais vous n'avez
jamais été aussi seul.
Et donc, nous sommes cette lumière
et il faut la garantir.
Or, en effet, vous avez
un certain nombre
d'urgentistes qui disent :
nous sommes un peu une élite,
nous ne verrons
que les urgences,
75 % des gens qui viennent
aux urgences n'ont
rien à y faire,
nous devons les éconduire
- ce qui conduit d'ailleurs
à des erreurs médicales,
soit dit en passant.
Non, il faut garantir ça,
c'est le sens de tout ça.
Et pour faire suite à ce que disait
monsieur Robinet fort justement,
à partir du moment
où vous avez un ONDAM qui est à 3,5,
quelque chose comme ça,
3,5 ou 3,6, et que vous avez
une inflation qui est à 8, 9, 10,
on est déficitaires,
donc on a perdu !
Vous voyez, les règles du jeu,
dès le début, sont pipées.
Vous ajoutez à ça que...
C'est bien,
de parler des boulangers,
j'adore mon boulanger,
son prix de l'énergie,
formidable,
le gouvernement va les aider,
mais personne ne parle
du coût majeur de l'énergie
pour les hôpitaux,
du budget pharaonique qu'il faut
pour chauffer un hôpital,
pour mettre l'électricité partout.
Et tout ça, ça fait que d'un coup,
on est écrasés et au bout du bout,
les infirmières, on ferme des lits,
donc vous avez embouteillage
aux urgences.
Et plus vous fermez de lits...
Regardez,
nous sommes passés en 10 ans
de 12 millions de fréquentation
des urgences
à plus de 24 millions, là.
Parce que derrière ça,
la permanence de soins,
le travail de nuit, le week-end,
les jours fériés a été délaissé.
Mais écoutez bien,
c'est très important :
c'est pas la faute
du gouvernement.
Quand il y a eu le Ségur,
dirigé par Castex,
l'ancien directeur
des hôpitaux, ils ont dit :
"Faut valoriser
la permanence de soins
"à la ville comme à l'hôpital."
Qui n'a pas voulu ?
Trois syndicats sur quatre.
Trois syndicats de praticiens
hospitaliers ont dit :
"On veut pas valoriser
la nuit et les jours fériés."
Bilan des courses,
il n'a même pas fallu attendre
des années, on est
dans une déconfiture totale
sur la permanence des soins,
à tel point
que pour la première fois
au moment des fêtes,
on a été obligés d'organiser
au SAMU de Paris
un véhicule léger pour aller faire
les certificats de décès,
car plus personne
ne voulait les faire, à Paris.
-On vous a écouté.
Je vais passer
à la médecine libérale,
mais avant de passer à ça,
une précision, Jacques Milliez.
Vous êtes à l'Académie nationale
de médecine.
Est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment que dans les réformes
qui sont envisagées
dans le domaine de la santé,
pas uniquement avec ce gouvernement,
mais disons
depuis quelques décennies,
les décisions qui sont prises
par les politiques
sont inscrites en...
J'allais dire "en collaboration",
mais en tout cas,
en tenant compte de vos avis ?
-Pas du tout.
Non, heureusement,
parce que je désapprouve
totalement les décisions
prises par les politiques
et j'entends pas beaucoup
les académies proposer
des choses constructives.
-La plupart
des ministres de la Santé
sont pourtant des médecins.
Bah oui...
-Le président
de l'Académie est Mattei,
l'ancien ministre catastrophique
de 2002, donc comment
tu veux faire tenir
l'Académie de médecine ?
-Laissez M. Milliez parler.
-C'est sûr,
on me demande un plan santé,
je le conçois comme un puzzle
où chacun va apporter
sa pièce, à condition
qu'elle s'articule
de façon harmonieuse
avec les autres,
mais un puzzle qui prend la santé,
le système de soins,
mais aussi ce qui n'est pas
le système de soins
et qui doit s'articuler avec.
Un exemple :
l'aménagement du territoire.
Comment on peut espérer
conserver un hôpital
de proximité, qui pourtant
est le premier employeur
de la ville dans bien des cas,
alors qu'il n'y a plus d'école,
plus de cinéma ?
Les gens s'en vont.
Comment peut-on contraindre
ou inciter des gens,
des soignants, à s'y installer ?
Alors...
Certains députés proposent
d'obliger les médecins
à venir s'y installer,
mais c'est illusoire.
Alors que déjà,
les médecins ne s'installent pas
alors qu'ils sont libres
de le faire où ils veulent,
comment s'installeraient-ils
là où ils ne veulent pas ?
Il n'y a pas de solution.
Pour l'instant,
c'est le noir absolu.
Je ne vois pas de solution.
Un autre exemple, vous permettez,
la féminisation de la profession
médicale, très bien.
Y a pas besoin
d'avoir lu Annie Ernaux
pour comprendre que les femmes
ont des vies multiples,
elles ont une vie professionnelle
et ont pour la plupart
une vie de famille
qui les oblige
et qui nous oblige
à tenir compte de l'amplitude
de l'ouverture des cabinets
et de la participation aux gardes.
Bon, le Parlement
est en train de voter une loi
qui va obliger
tous les soignants libéraux
à participer aux gardes.
Vous croyez que les femmes
mères de famille vont le faire ?
Comme l'obligation vaccinale
pour les soignants, certains
vont s'y conformer, d'autres non.
Et dans la suite,
si on veut pas être vacciné,
on se fait pas soignant,
si on veut pas faire de gardes,
on devient pas médecin.
-Tout ce que dit
le professeur Milliez
est important
et ça reflète deux choses.
C'est la méconnaissance totale
de ces professions,
la méconnaissance jusqu'à l'oubli,
et l'incapacité
prévisionnelle.
Avant, on avait des politiques
qui faisaient des plans quinquennaux
et aujourd'hui, on a des politiques
qui raisonnent au mois.
-A l'urgence.
-Et ça, c'est dramatique.
C'est dramatique.
Si vous ajoutez la méconnaissance
à l'incapacité prévisionnelle,
vous arrivez à ce qu'on connaît.
Vous arrivez à des politiques
qui disent "Y a qu'à les obliger"
sans se rendre compte
que chaque désert est différent.
Un désert,
c'est une empreinte digitale.
Si vous mettez pas
autour de la table
toutes les forces d'un territoire,
vous ne résoudrez pas ce désert.
Vous remarquerez
que la question simple
qui préside à la solution
du problème,
qui est celle du pourquoi
les médecins sont partis,
n'est jamais posée, jamais.
Pourquoi ils sont partis ?
Cette question n'a pas la même
réponse dans chaque territoire.
-Jérôme Marty,
parlons
de votre domaine,
puisque vous êtes censé défendre
les médecins généralistes.
Dans ce domaine,
il y a deux secteurs,
le secteur conventionné,
dit secteur 1,
et le secteur dit 2
où les honoraires
sont libres.
On a vu ces derniers temps
que la revendication
de tous les syndicats généralistes
était de porter la consultation
de 25 à 50 euros.
Ca ne s'est pas fait,
mais à votre avis, vous croyez
que c'est faisable, au regard
des finances de l'Etat ?
Où trouver
les 9 milliards nécessaires
à cette chose-là ?
Est-ce que c'est le seul problème
qui règlerait,
si je puis dire,
la situation des généralistes ?
-Déjà,
c'est pas 9 milliards.
Monter à 50 euros,
si on intègre dans ce tarif
les forfaits,
toutes les entrées qu'on peut avoir
autour du tarif de 25 euros,
c'est en gros
entre 1 et 3 milliards.
Mais si vous rendez attractif
ce métier,
si vous avez plus de médecins,
si ces médecins s'occupent mieux
de l'addictologie
et des ALD...
-C'est quoi, "ALD" ?
-Les affections
longue durée.
1 euro dépensé :
5 euros de bénéfice pour le pays.
Ca veut dire que la santé
n'est pas un coût,
c'est un investissement,
mais il faut investir
dans les mains qui soignent,
ce qu'on ne veut pas faire
et c'est grave.
50 euros, ça peut choquer,
mais quand vous prenez
les revendications,
que vous avez trois niveaux
de consultation ou non,
en gros, vous retrouvez
la moyenne européenne à 50.
Que vous ayez
des forfaits ou non,
vous en arrivez là.
A 25 euros,
vous créez le désert médical.
Si vous voulez vous implanter
dans Paris, au prix des loyers,
vous pouvez pas
faire tourner un cabinet.
Si vous voulez aller
à la campagne
avec la désindustrialisation
et le chômage sans services publics,
qui ont déserté,
avec 25 euros, c'est pas possible.
Vous ne vous en sortez pas.
Si vous n'avez pas dans la tête
que la santé est devenue
le deuxième métier du ménage,
ça, c'est primordial.
Avant, dans un couple,
la santé était le premier métier.
Aujourd'hui, c'est le deuxième.
Le conjoint ou la conjointe
a un métier
plus technique que le médecin.
En ruralité, vous ne pouvez pas
trouver un métier.
C'est une difficulté.
-M. Marty, j'ai entendu
les pouvoirs publics
dire que ce que gagnaient
les médecins généralistes,
y compris en secteur 1,
n'était pas
défavorisé par rapport
à ce qu'ils pouvaient
gagner dans d'autres pays d'Europe,
c'est vrai ?
-Mais non...
-Il faut aussi comparer...
-Il faut aussi arrêter
de raisonner à l'instant T,
mais raisonner sur une vie,
raisonner au nombre d'heures,
à l'épuisement,
au rôle et à la responsabilité.
Dans un calcul,
ces facteurs entrent en jeu.
Si vous restez
sur ce qu'il y a en bas
à droite de la feuille,
ça ne va pas.
On en reste sur l'économie pure,
qui ne peut pas présider à la santé.
-J'ai une question précise.
Le paiement à l'acte,
pour nos téléspectateurs,
c'est-à-dire quand un patient
va chez un médecin,
y a une consultation,
c'est un acte.
Et donc, on doit payer
aujourd'hui en secteur 1,
c'est-à-dire conventionné,
remboursé
par la Sécurité sociale,
25 euros.
Si c'est en secteur 2,
ça peut être deux fois,
trois fois, etc.
Ce paiement
à l'acte, ça ne pousse pas
à l'inflation des actes
pour se retrouver financièrement ?
Est-ce que vous seriez favorable
à ce que ça évolue ?
Dans certains pays
scandinaves, on a un forfait
annuel par patient,
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas
le nombre d'actes, mais il y a
une somme qui est consacrée
à soigner le patient.
J'aimerais avoir votre avis à tous.
Cela permettrait
de ne pas avoir cette inflation
et ça permettrait aux patients
et aux médecins de s'en sortir.
-Ce qui pousse à l'inflation,
c'est le manque de médecins.
Quand j'embauche à 7h du matin,
j'ai ouvert une consultation
de 7h à 8h pour permettre
aux gens qui n'ont pas de médecin
de trouver un médecin.
Le soir, quand j'arrête,
j'en ai laissé plusieurs
au bord de la route.
C'est ça qui fait monter.
C'est pas le reste.
Sur le secteur 2, comme vous dites,
honoraires libres,
dans des spécialités,
sans honoraires libres,
ces spécialités disparaissent
car les actes n'ont pas
été revalorisés depuis 30 ans.
-Et sur le fait de changer
ce système, comme le font
les Scandinaves ?
-Ils ont mis en place
le paiement au parcours de soin,
et ça, c'est magique.
Ceux qui le veulent disent :
"Les complications
en chirurgie ont disparu."
Evidemment.
Dans l'enveloppe,
ces complications
ne sont pas prises en compte.
Elles ne sont pas dans l'enveloppe.
Les directions hospitalières
disent au médecin :
"Choisis des malades
qui ne sont pas à risque."
Est-ce que c'est vraiment
ce système qu'on veut ?
Je pense pas.
-M. Robinet,
sur le paiement à l'acte,
vous voudriez que ça évolue ?
-C'était l'annonce
du président de la République
lors de ses voeux
au personnel de santé.
Aujourd'hui, le paiement
à l'acte représente
à peu près 50 %
des recettes de l'hôpital.
Nous y sommes favorables, à ça,
à la suppression du tout TAA,
bien évidemment.
Mais ça doit concerner
le secteur public
comme le secteur privé,
je pense aux cliniques.
A la FHF, nous ne sommes pas opposés
à avoir des financements
qui sont orientés en fonction
des objectifs de santé publique
et en termes de missions.
C'est aussi une chose
qu'avait demandée la FHF,
revoir ce TAA,
ou ce tout TAA,
dans le financement de l'hôpital,
qui ne représente
que 50 % du financement.
-On va essayer d'ouvrir,
quand même,
une perspective,
on ne va pas rester
dans ce pessimisme-là.
Vous êtes,
en tant que médecins
ou responsables
des hôpitaux,
vous êtes là pour soigner
et donner de l'espoir aux gens.
-Et garantir l'accès aux soins.
-Tout à fait, ce qui rend
les gens plus optimistes
et plus heureux.
La question que je vous pose,
c'est qu'on a vu qu'il y avait
beaucoup de trous dans la raquette
et que ça ne va pas bien
à la fois
pour la médecine libérale,
la médecine hospitalière,
les urgences, etc.
Les jeunes générations
ont du mal à s'installer, etc.
Mais la santé,
bien sûr, c'est un droit.
Mais ça,
c'est pour le citoyen.
Au niveau des pouvoirs publics,
c'est un système de rationnement
à travers la Sécurité sociale, etc.
Les professionnels de santé,
vous avez
à vous accommoder de cette chose-là.
Au-delà des investissements,
des dépenses à faire,
est-ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui
que la situation justifierait
une nouvelle loi-cadre,
quelque chose qui serait plus
qu'une grande réforme,
mais des états généraux de la santé
pour remettre
tout le monde à la table ?
Les généralistes, les hospitaliers,
les urgentistes, les mandarins...
Pardonnez-moi,
c'est comme ça qu'on appelle
les grands patrons en médecine,
sans connotation
asiatique.
Est-ce que ça vous paraît
une bonne chose, Patrick Pelloux ?
-Ca a déjà été fait
des dizaines de fois.
-Ca servirait,
au regard de la gravité ?
-Au regard de la gravité,
moi, je crois à la démocratie,
je crois à l'importance
des parlements.
Il faudrait probablement inventer
quelque chose de nouveau
qui ne soit pas
cette espèce de guignolerie
du tirage au sort de citoyens.
Ca, c'est n'importe quoi.
Totalement d'accord,
il faut remettre les maires
présidents du conseil
d'administration des hôpitaux
parce que vous avez...
Les maires, c'est les meilleurs
représentants
des besoins de la population,
premièrement.
Deuxièmement, en effet,
définir une loi-cadre qui soit
aux deux tiers
non pas des deux assemblées,
mais des trois assemblées,
car on oublie toujours le conseil
économique et social,
qui fait des rapports fabuleux
où ils écoutent tout le monde,
où vous avez
dans ce parlement
les représentants syndicaux,
y compris des médecins libéraux.
Donc, nous avons,
la France a la capacité
de faire cette consultation,
mais elle ne veut pas.
Je me souviens,
en 2014, nous avons participé
à une consultation
sur les personnes âgées.
Le conseil économique a fait
un rapport remarquable
à l'unanimité des représentants
du conseil, ça n'est pas écouté.
En fait, quand les parlements
décident quelque chose,
ce n'est pas écouté,
parce que des lobbies importants
ne veulent pas
faire changer les choses.
-Deux mots.
Les lobbies, c'est certains
syndicats médicaux ?
-Non, non.
C'est souvent
les industries pharmaceutiques,
c'est beaucoup plus vaste que ça.
L'un des plus gros lobbyiste
au niveau
du Parlement européen
est le Big Pharma.
Il faut savoir
que tout ce dont on parle,
ça fait consommer du médicament,
parfois de manière abusive,
et donc, y a des gens
qui se goinfrent dessus.
-M. Marty, sur ce point, loi-cadre ?
-Il faut une réforme systémique.
Il faut arrêter de bricoler,
il faut une grande réforme,
qui ne peut passer
que par une démocratie sanitaire,
ce qui n'existe pas,
dans notre pays.
On doit pouvoir avoir,
à la gouvernance du soin,
à la fois les soignants
et l'administration,
mais également les patients.
Il faut libérer les patients
de la tutelle de l'Etat.
Ils sont financés
par la tutelle de l'Etat,
il faut les rendre totalement libres
pour qu'ils décident.
Il faut un droit d'opposition.
Le système ne doit pouvoir avancer
que si les trois parties
sont d'accord.
C'est fondamental.
Et puis, il faut croire en l'homme.
Je suis optimiste.
Le balancier est allé tellement loin
dans la déshumanisation
qu'il va revenir
et on va croire en l'homme.
Aujourd'hui, on a à la fois
des hôpitaux qui s'effondrent
et dans la crise
naissent les monstres.
La financiarisation pose la main
sur le soin, on le voit
dans une commercialisation du soin.
C'est extrêmement dangereux.
Si le politique ne prend pas
en compte ce facteur-là
qui naît de la déshumanisation
et du fait qu'on a écarté
les soignants de la décision
et qu'on a laissé le marché...
-On vous a entendu.
Jacques Milliez ?
-Une concertation, un nouveau Ségur,
y en a déjà eu beaucoup
et je vois pas
ce que ça apporterait de plus.
Je vais faire deux remarques.
Toute l'Europe est en crise,
pas seulement nous,
et personne n'a de solution.
L'Espagne, le Portugal,
la Grèce,
l'Allemagne, et je parle pas
de la Grande-Bretagne.
Donc, où trouver les solutions ?
Deuxièmement,
il faut avoir conscience
que nous nous considérons,
comme dit Patrick,
en urgence absolue.
Mais on n'est pas les seuls.
Regardons l'armée.
L'armée a obtenu 400 milliards
de budget en disant :
"Nous ne pouvons plus soutenir
un conflit de haute intensité."
-Jacques Milliez,
on est sortis
du "quoi qu'il en coûte".
-Les 400 milliards
à l'armée ?
Comment peut-on "compétiter" ?
-La guerre est en Europe.
M. Robinet ?
-Sortons de la politique
des petits pas,
que ce soit sur le sanitaire
ou le grand âge.
On nous promet les grands soins.
Je ne veux de CNR et autres.
Le constat est connu,
le diagnostic est unanime.
Maintenant, il nous faut des actes.
J'ai entendu le président qui,
dans son discours,
donne des ambitions, des directions.
C'est très bien.
Il reprend les inquiétudes
des usagers, des patients.
-Mais il vous écoute,
quand vous lui parlez ?
-Je...
Je n'ai pas contact direct
avec le président,
mon contact est le ministre
de la Santé ou des Solidarités
ou la ministre déléguée.
On a un contact régulier.
Oui, il y a une écoute,
mais comme on le dit,
il faut ensuite des preuves.
Nous attendons
que le gouvernement
agisse.
Le diagnostic est connu,
il y a des solutions.
-Mais vous êtes
pour des états généraux ?
-Si c'est pour perdre encore
6 mois pour refaire le diagnostic,
vous savez...
Le constat a été fait
entre nous,
lors de cette émission.
On le connaît.
Aujourd'hui, il y a des propositions
apportées par la FHF
comme par les syndicats
de médecins libéraux,
par d'autres syndicats,
d'autres fédérations.
Je souhaite que...
A la rigueur, n'attendons pas
d'injonctions de l'Etat.
Mettons-nous,
les représentants de la santé,
autour de la table
et sortons de table
quand c'est réglé.
-La crise est européenne,
mais la France est un phare,
un exemple
au niveau de la santé.
Cette responsabilité-là nous oblige.
-OK. Merci.
Le mot de la fin nous oblige,
comme vous dites.
Il me reste à présenter un peu
une bibliographie.
Vous avez tous publié des livres,
même s'ils sont pas
d'une brûlante actualité.
Arnaud Robinet,
avec Jacques Bichot,
vous avez écrit
il y a quelques années
"La mort de l'Etat providence :
"Vive les assurances sociales !"
Il est toujours d'actualité ?
-Je ne suis pas sûr,
au vu de la situation.
Mais pour la prise en charge
et le financement,
on aura besoin de tout le monde
dans la prise en charge
de nos aînés.
L'évolution de la société,
le vieillissement de la population,
on doit s'adapter
de façon transversale
et on aura besoin
de tout le monde,
car c'est un devoir
de prendre soin de nos aînés
et de leur permettre d'avoir
une fin de vie, je dirais, digne.
-Merci, M. Robinet.
Patrick Pelloux,
"Urgences de vivre"
au Cherche midi.
-Y a longtemps.
-Vous restez dans l'urgence.
-Toujours.
Merci, ça me fait plaisir.
-Il avait plus de cheveux.
-C'est vrai.
-Pourquoi vous avez associé
"urgences"
et "vivre" ?
-Parce que je pense
que les deux sont intimement liés,
en fait.
-Jérôme Marty,
vous avez publié
"Le scandale
des soignants contaminés"
chez Flammarion.
Ca reste un problème, ça ?
Vous avez voulu dénoncer...
-Ca a été à l'aune
de tout ce qu'on a dit,
l'oubli des soignants.
On a organisé la covid
sans tenir compte
des soignants, sans les protéger
parce qu'économiquement,
on avait fait des coupes
sur des endroits où on pensait
que ça servirait pas, quoi.
On a oublié d'armer les soignants,
ça a été catastrophique et ça a créé
cette contamination avec des morts,
une médecine générale
qui a payé cher
avec 75 morts de soignants.
-Oui.
-On a vécu un drame absolu.
On espère une chose,
c'est qu'on le revivra plus.
Là aussi, si les patients
avaient été là
dans l'organisation,
ils auraient pas banqué les masques.
-Jacques Milliez,
vous reprenez la tradition
des grands médecins
qui ont une attraction
pour la littérature.
Vous avez publié bien des ouvrages,
même des romans policiers,
je crois.
Vous avez publié un ouvrage
sur la GPA.
Vous avez évolué, depuis,
sur la GPA
ou vous considérez...
-Oui, j'ai évolué,
je suis extrêmement convaincu
que c'est un bon traitement
des stérilités utérines,
ce qui ne va pas dans le sens
de l'opinion publique,
mais c'est ni le lieu ni le moment
de débattre de cela.
-Voilà, merci.
Ils rient.
Merci, messieurs,
d'avoir participé activement
à cette émission
et d'avoir défendu
ce qui est votre domaine,
à savoir la santé.
Merci à l'équipe de LCP
qui permet la réalisation
de cette émission.
Avant de nous quitter, je voudrais
vous laisser avec cette pensée :
"En cette nouvelle année,
"on ne demande pas grand-chose,
du travail
"et de la santé."
Patrick Pelloux,
c'est qui, à votre avis ?
-Euh...
De M. Robinet.
-M. Robinet ?
Non, c'est pas de M. Robinet,
c'est d'un auteur
que nous choyons, Albert Camus.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA